it may be mid-winter but Europe is in a
heat wave eight countries have had their
warmest ever January day from Latvia and
Belarus in the East to the Netherlands
in the west new Regional records have
also been set in France Germany and
Spain the south of England is just on
the fringes mild but not exceptionally
so but look at these temperatures Warsaw
in Poland reached 18.9 degrees on New
Year's Day that's four degrees higher
than the previous record and Bill Bauer
in Northern Spain reached 24.9 degrees
that's the average temperature for July
it's meant Beach weather for some and
what should be the coldest time of year
normally temperature records are beaten
by a few tenths of a degree this time
they've been smashed by so much over
such a large area that some
meteorologists are calling this an
extreme weather event the reason is a
mass of warm air over North Africa which
has itself been exceptionally hot on
land and at Sea this map shows how
unusual the current water temperatures
orange and red is much hotter than
normal off the coast of West Africa and
in the Mediterranean is two or three
degrees above average it's like a giant
radiator heating up the air and as the
jet stream the winds several miles up in
the atmosphere have shifted North
they've drawn up that hot air to Europe
now we do get these weather patterns
setting up we have seen that in the past
but because of climate change because
we've turned that background kind of
temperature up by a degree or so it
means that when we get these weather
patterns like this the temperatures are
higher than they would normally be
2022 was the hottest year on record for
the UK Ireland France and Spain 2023 is
already off to a barmy start